[Music]  what's going on i'm the league hi miles  we're malikin miles and where are mit  undergraduates and we're gonna talk  about the top five reasons to study the  brain coming in at five you can find the  cure to any biological disease that  affects the brain number four you can  literally learn the biology that governs  behavior coming in at three you can  understand the most complex thing in the  known universe besides us that is  [Music]  number two pop quiz what is the only  organ that has named itself  it's the brain and finally number one  and is the most important neurons have  the coolest shape of literally any cell  like a normal cell is like this but a  neuron  if they're not animating this this will  look really weird  but if you're not convinced  this will change your mind one and two  and  [Music]  we'll see you next time bye  you